I want you to think briefly here we go I
want you to briefly about this about
this to watch again as I replay it and
watch super carefully where he releases
the discus okay where he releases that's
what I want you to sit
okay okay all right good good so I hope
you saw that now by the way um I just
one more time before I turn it off I'll
let you what you saw was like what's his
right leg carefully watch his right leg
you watch as governor watch his right
leg this one that's whipping around it
should you watch what it does
and think about it yeah he does more
than B makes a circle because more than
that actually I'll come back to
discussing that in a minute
it's quite something to watch it's quite
something it all happens usually too
fast for us to like scrutinize what's
having an understanding and that's why I
had to find some slow-mo fridges yeah
sort of
so we'll come back to this idea okay the
question I asked was the question house
was where did he release
where did he release okay so he wants it
if you want we were like standing from
behind him okay and he wanted the discus
to go straight out in front straight out
of front okay
so as he like ripped around he actually
released if you can't really watch
pretty much there exactly there and then
you can see the discus fly off okay down
fat oh yeah I yeah I do have this on a
wire for this just so you can see it
moment by moment okay so this this is
him spinning around right you see you
can see this the discus tried to
highlight it and he's moving around in a
circle right so he's enzyme is going
around around around it moves a little
bit further
oh you can see he's still moving in a
circle but as he gets to the end this is
that point of release is that this is
the point of release and you can see the
tangential velocity that's heading off
in addition because that's where he
wants to send his discus which is indeed
where it goes you can see that's where
he's released it does that make sense
now discus is particularly cool for
circular motion because it's circular
motion for this brief like
one-and-a-half seconds and then it
becomes it's a projectile yeah right it
because projectile motion right so it's
particularly interesting because stop
both hands fixed so maybe what you want
to write down underneath this diagram is
we call the tangent to a velocity
because it is always facing it's always
facing in the direction of the tangent
at your point right all the particles
point
they go same position okay wonderful now
we've got we've got language to describe
all this stuff over here we've got
algebra all that kind of thing how can
we describe this now remember this thing
is moving in a curved path okay so even
though I draw all of these straight
lines none of them is adequate to
actually describe the motion because
there are just straight lines in here at
all what so in fact to measure this
linear velocity is the velocity I had to
actually include a curve right something
like this okay that's that's an actual
path that the object will travel along
now how do I work out how far something
has gone around the edge of a circle
what shape is that it's an arc right
it's a buck so what I need is arc length
now thankfully I know he's a Radian
measure that will help me here in fact
is whether superyachts results you can
have right how do I work out the length
of an arc
what do what piece of pressure do I need
to know I need to know the radius of
this circle right and then I said oh oh
surprise this arm this angle here right
I need to know what kind of angle has
changed over the time that I was looking
at right so if I know that then the
linear displacement is going to be
proportional to the angular displacement
you see that and the proportion is the
radius now it's the same thing with
velocity if I define this linear
velocity linear velocity as V it's going
be by definition is how much this Elvis
alkylate this changes right so by
definition I call it DL or detail right
but we just stated that L is just our
Thea it's just L is just a label for
Athena right so this is really do DT of
V dot right now ah and theta sometimes
you have to be able to be careful
because we have so many protein was
flying around and this is why when you
can you get to a university-level mass
and this is
very typical of that you're like oh
where are the numbers you know oh look
numbers okay they come up very often
when you have a look at our data is this
a circular motion so one of these is
variable and one of these is not which
one is variable which one's constant
radius is constant but theater is
changing all the time right that's kind
of the point okay so in fact being that
radius is closer I can pull it out the
front it's just lit number ah times D
theta on DT but I already gave DP by DT
that name
that's angular velocity isn't it so I'm
gonna call this ah alright so just like
linear displacement maybe a displacement
was proportional to angular displacement
linear velocity is also proportional to
angular velocity vector so you may like
to write that down here linear velocity
proportional to okay mm-hmm right now
let's let's keep on digging into this
this um we have lots of different kinds
of questions that we can ask about this
but I want us to start off simple with
the principle right I want to start
thinking about if angular velocity is
just a number if it's a constant if its
value doesn't change over time right if
this is which arm would you try to do
but mostly failed okay if this is GPS is
um going around and a constant angular
velocity right then because they're
proportional to each other is also
constant linear velocity so we call that
situation if underneath that if Omega if
angular velocity and therefore they do
velocity if it's just a number if it's a
constant okay then we call this motion
we call it beautiful one circular motion
okay so that's my little something is
uniform circular which is um it's a
tricky phrase it's a tricky phrase
because when you hear the word uniform
you're like is this some is this like
Newton's first law it talks about
uniform motion of no forces acting on
things it's not in this first law it's
not inertia right can someone tell me
why even though we're using the word
uniform which seems to do that and
though force is acting uniform circular
motion
actually there is and there must be a
force a resultant force acting all the
time what are you gonna get okay very
good so angular displacement sorry
angular velocity could be a constant
number and that will make linear
velocity a constant number but the
actual velocity right the actual
velocity which includes direction the
actual loss is always changing look you
can even see it it's like I'm facing
this way then I'm facing that way I'm
facing that way the magnitude is the
same but the velocity itself which
includes Direction is always changing
don't worry too much okay all right so
um like I've just established right this
is actually the inertia is not operating
right there is actually a force a
nonzero force acting on this and usually
that force to be something like say well
you tell me what's something that moves
around in a circle right we've got lots
of them you know solar system alright
say like a satellite or a moon right
we'll get your answers in a second right
if you got a moon or satellite or
something like that rotating orbiting
around what is the force that's acting
on this is constantly changing the
direction suit gravity right
so because our gravity gravity is very
clothing cause you could also say ah I
might be absolutely let's talk about the
ferris wheel for instance I might
actually be attached to something right
if you're attached then the name of that
force that's holding you there is called
late ideas believe me we could have big
in deep deep further into your physics
ideas yesterday Oh we'll get to that and
people pause on that one we'll come to
that level right so I just want you to
know the actual velocity is always
changing so that's what's going